come on you think me getting naked so if
I just took off my clothes and said take
some pictures with me that would be as
easy as building that building no it's
different obviously but I do think that
both of them have difficulties no but I
equal such thing as equal okay okay I
would say one but you have to pick which
one's harder I won't pick one no not for
me man taking off clothes oh come on you
know if you just take out your clothes
you're not gonna make the money that a
guy is gonna do you know how much they
make there are women
a month on only fans you're a women
making a million a month on only fans
yeah and you think that's more important
than the men who are voting these roads
so what are you saying I'm not saying
it's more important I say that it has
the same value if it's not as important